what's going on guys Terminator Genisys
the trailer is out there it's on the
streets and people have a lot of
opinions about it some people like it
some people are like not so fast
we brought in our resident fixer mr.
Nick Mundy to let us know his thoughts
on it Nick how one would think after
Terminator 3 and Mickey's Terminator
that uh humanity might be done with the
terminators for a while stay paneled
terminators right many said the war
between man and machine over and the
Machine of studio executives one here we
are because the powers that be decided
hey man we need new terminators if you
don't start making new terminators I'll
stop making lists on how to fix them God
hears my ways to fix Terminator no more
Arnold whoa he is the Terminator he was
the Terminator Arnold can't act anymore
he just can't all he can do is look
right into the camera and say I'll be
back I'll be back
what that's it I don't want him in a
movie about The Terminator because it's
just embarrassing
the computer-generated Arnold looks more
compelling than the real Arnold so do
you want zero all right you know what
the prime scene that the producers of
the new terminators had balls they would
cut Arnold out completely
mm-hmm so you're talking hasta LaVista
Arnold yes yeah I cannot believe as a
fan a huge fan of both Terminator and
Arnold Schwarzenegger that I'm saying
that the Terminator movie would be
better without Arnold you don't have a
hard that is for me as a child could you
ever imagine yourself saying that no I
feel like I'm saying I don't want to see
wrestling without all Colgan but here we
are
Wow I know like that's what they could
that's what is that to me those are
these are my real feelings kill him off
forever end it done for good new
Terminator just get a new Terminator got
it Mundy what's next
make it a one-off
Studios as you know are very desperate
for for franchises they just want to
make mega franchises of all the work and
taken by taking an existing IP like
Terminator and just strip-mining it you
know it knows great about Ghostbusters
and Back to the Future and die hard and
the original Terminator is they wrote a
great movie and then shot it and made it
and then let the consumer decide hey
this is a great movie we demand more
instead all we're gonna get is these
half-assed movies with even worse
sequels and even terrible three equals
and even God more god-awful branded web
content I just like to go on the record
saying that we here at screen junkies
have no problem with branded web content
they had their head so far up the ass
that they just can't make a good movie
so instead of getting a great terminator
hey guys guess what you're gonna get
five terrible sequels and the [ __ ]
adventures of young miles Dyson the
spin-off series on Cheers dot TV with
the what adventures the funky okay funky
the [ __ ] adventures of young miles
doesn't I thought you said a bad word
Nick what else you got for us if you're
gonna reboot the franchise reboot the
franchise producers of the new
Terminator franchise have stated that
it's neither a sequel or a reboot yeah
well which is it yeah well they're just
trying to be cute the reason for like
not giving a definitive answer is
because they're trying not to piss off
the fans of the originals while trying
to like you know do what they need to do
so no one's upset they're trying to Star
Trek us all this movie is going to be as
hey remember the scenes you liked in the
first two terminators we're doing the
same thing but Robert Patrick is now
Asian what we got to do is actually
start the story over do something
different you know what we haven't seen
in a Terminator movie a baby Terminator
no no no all we need is robots
destroying and going back in time but
this time the robots are the good guys
well like in Terminator 2 Linda Hamilton
was the hero of that movie I mean Nick
haven't we been down this road with
Robocop yeah but that's not Robocop's
fault
that's the people who made Robocop if
they made a great
Robocop reboot that's completely
different I would have been fine with
that but they did it it was obvious
Michael Keaton the bad guy who does that
cowards do that we got it Nick
give us another one bring back james
cameron nicolson Egger you don't want to
continue the same story but you want to
bring the old director back who better
to reinvent the Terminator franchise
than the guy who invented is he our only
hope he is our only hope
he is our Kyle Reese in this whole story
why getting James Cameron is important
is for many reasons but two specific
reasons why we need James Cameron back
one he's the only guy who knows how to
make a good Terminator movie and two the
other reason why this is great yeah is
because he would be so busy working on
Terminator like he should have been
doing for the last 20 years that he
won't have time to worry about any see
avatar movies we all win
we've got great terminators no more
terrible advertorial movies I'm standing
there you're winners there's gonna be
there's gonna be more unobtainium
there's gonna be more home-tree
there's gonna be more Navi I don't know
if Jake Sully's gonna be back Oh No
if they can just get Jai Courtney that
sounds like a very scary thought and it
also sounds like a segue what's next no
more Jai Courtney look Taylor Kitsch had
two chances to fail and he failed and
and we moved on but Jai Courtney reason
he's in a bunch of movies killer kids
would be a much better calories no but
instead we get you know this this fella
yeah he's an Aussie with a chin
he's a mystery saying hey guys Sam
Worthington doesn't want to do more
Terminator movies
alright let's go down the list Jack
Courtney fantastic I mean I'm sure he's
a good dude but man you boom give us
another one spell Genesis right
okay what else and then my final point
don't make any more terminators wait
what were we just doing here giving them
a template to how to make good ones
still man we should have just ended at
Terminator 2 wait Turner one was a great
taste it was a great appetizer to get
your beak wet grass oh yes yes you
German one this is an interesting meal
I'll enjoy this I'm not very I'm a bird
I think it'd make me quick yeah but then
Turner too just topped in every single
way it's like you can't herminator too
drenched my beak you can't top a perfect
movie you can't make a better movie than
perfect and Terminator 2 is a perfect
movie we had it all wrapped up Judgment
Day was stopped good guys won yeah we
don't need to do more what they wanted
to go to the bank again a lot of you're
like hey what movies should they reboot
what rubra movie they should remake they
shouldn't they should just make new
movies see in the 80s he just ripped
each other off yeah they didn't remake
things knock-offs knockoff Tejon cash
was a ripoff a lethal weapon but they
were both awesome Nick I think you've
given the makers of Terminator some
exciting options and I think you've also
given them reason to do a little
soul-searching how I think every once in
a while we need to search our souls for
something important do you think there
should be any more Terminator movies are
you uncomfortable as I am with Nick
holding my hand let us know in the
comments section below best answer we're
gonna send you a screen junkies t-shirt
I want to thank you for watching I want
to thank our resident fixer dr. Nick
Mundy thank you for that I'm Hal Rudnick
hit me up on Twitter bye-bye you did
make more money than the Russo brothers
with Captain America Winter Soldier
those great guys and made a great film
does that mean they have to wash your
car now or something that's part of I
think that's part of their
renegotiations is they have to do some
of my basic you know not what like buy
microwave